so the things you do in computers and
the things you do on your phone yep bite
dance look at this we're going to take a
look at this so we're going to leave
this chart up for a little while here
and talk over this one yeah absolutely I
will take the lead here uh so obviously
we see on this chart the annual revenue
since being founded we see that meta is
on the top but meta is also year 16 17
or 17-18 uh where the only other
Contender here is bite dance which is
also known as Tick Tock the parent
company
um and they're at 85 billion and you're
looking at there at year what nine so
they've reached
85 of the same Revenue that meta has in
half the time so I think I think there's
multiple components to this that has
allowed it I think that the one of the
things that I'd be interested in seeing
here is like when these different
companies were were started and like how
much slower it is versus uh bite dance
obviously has been out for a couple
years now and they've really hammered on
the mobile only and that's where we've
seen a rapid growth because now everyone
has phones and then obviously they've
been good at hitting a social media for
a younger demographic which is exploding
on that end and if you look at the 80
they hit this 85 billion number like
you're eight nine and you look at our
16-17 that's when uh meta hit 85 billion
total sales and that's long after they
had WhatsApp long after they have
Instagram and they had added tremendous
other functionality to meta it was
before they started throwing money into
the shredder on the metaverse but you
take a look there bite dances got to
that number in exactly half the time and
here year 18 YouTube sitting there at 29
billion which is about a third yeah I
think right at a third a third of the
revenue in twice the years and never
mind uh you know poor little uh Twitter
or X I guess there should be the expert
and Snapchat in there they've never
really had the driven economic
underpinnings that that Facebook did or
that YouTube did and now you see what
bite dance is doing primarily with
influencers although you're correct bite
dance started when we had a whole new
generation a second generation not a
first generation a second generation of
digital natives who grew up on digital
but grew up on mobile we knew that from
PHP the Fantastic
um a company that Patrick Bet David
founded back 2009-2010 time frame and
you see what happened there the software
that he built had to have mobile
components because they demand it
because they don't the generation that
became insurance agents on this
incredible platform that Patrick built
you know they don't go to Starbucks like
their moms dads aunts and uncles didn't
sit there for three hours with the
laptop they're on mobile they're on the
larger mobile screens the you know
iPhone plus and it's got to work at
least partially well on on the phone so
not only their digital native they're
mobile digital Natives and that is the
group that bite dances figured out that
ad model too and they've got to 85
billion let alone the algorithm
obviously the the tick tock algorithm is
is something else where they're getting
people they're getting them hooked in
and people are really seeing a lot on
that and the other interesting part that
I looked at on the numbers here is bike
dance is more than 2x YouTube Twitter
and Snapchat's combined so it goes to
show how monstrous it is because I
thought YouTube was way bigger in terms
of numbers just in terms of the the
platform let alone that it's also a
Google platform but it's still being
slaughtered by both by dance and um
meta or Facebook on that end although
you know tick tock's got great features
like that new feature hey Tick Tock I
said hey Tick Tock how much money does
my brother have in his checking account
it knew so it's just kind of amazing it
probably has nothing to do with the data
leaks going back to China or anything
but I just thought it was really kind of
a fantastic new feature
[Music]